st. Patrick's Day is right around the
corner and that's of course a big day
for myself and of course the show that's
why I thought why not right now bring
out one of our favorite characters drink
and dancin Danny Doyle
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
stop the music okay wait a minute wait a
minute wait a minute I'm sorry we're all
having a good time what's your problem
sir you don't like drink and dance and
Danny Doyle for F sake so Brian it's an
embarrassment that's not real Irish take
off your hats your wig your beard I bet
you're not even Irish I bet your name's
not even Danny Doyle okay well what is
your name by the way it's a marker chefs
key you see I told you real Irish don't
celebrate with fake beards and
leprechaun costumes you want to know
what real Irish is Conan well yes I'd
like to know what real Eris's yeah well
then come here
real Irish is not making rent until you
win a hand of Poker against your own
mother real Irish is get into a bar
fight with a girl and when she beats you
ask her to marry her wait a minute I
think I'm getting it yeah
one question real random question random
Irish guy from the audience what are you
drinkin from Bushmills the world's
oldest whiskey distillery it's red bush
a smooth whiskey blend aged in American
bourbon barrels for a sweeter taste red
bush huh you're gonna drink the whole
bottle you can't got to be up at 6:00
a.m. tomorrow for my job as a systems
analyst hard work that's real Irish and
now change the sad sappy Irish music to
something more updates
[Applause]
[Music]
he's hiding some kind of a sick
[Applause]
you